we've all been hearing that deep neural
networks work really well for a lot of
problems it's not just that they need to
be big neural networks is that
specifically they need to be deep or to
have a lot of hidden layers so why is
that let's go for a couple examples and
try to gain some intuition for why deep
networks might work well so first what
is a deep network computing if you're
building a system for face recognition
or face detection here's what the deep
neural network could be doing
perhaps you input a picture of a face
then the first layer of the neural
network you can think of as maybe being
a feature detector or an edge detector
in this example I'm plotting what a
neural network with maybe twenty hidden
units might be trying to compute on this
image with the twenty hidden units
visualized by these little square boxes
so for example this little visualization
represents a hidden unit that's trying
to figure out if you know where the
edges of that orientation are in the
image and maybe this hidden unit might
be trying to figure out where are the
horizontal edges in this image and when
we talk about convolutional networks in
a later course of this particular
visualization we'll make a bit more
sense but the form you can think of the
first lived in your network as looking a
picture and trying to figure out you
know where are the edges in this picture
now let's figure out where the edges in
this picture by grouping together pixels
to form edges it can then take the
detected edges and group edges together
to form parts of faces so for example
you might have a loner on trying to see
if is finding an eye or a different
neuron trying to find that part of the
nose and so by putting together lots of
edges it can start to detect different
parts of faces and then finally by
putting together different parts of
faces that can I or a nose or an ear or
chin it can then try to recognize or
detect different types of faces so
intuitively you can think of the earlier
layers of a neural network is detecting
simpler functions like edges
then composing them together in the
later layers of a neural network so that
they can learn one more complex
functions these visualizations will make
more sense when we talk about
convolutional nets and one technical
detail of this visualization the edge
detectors are looking in relatively
small areas of an image may be very
small regions like that and then the
facial detectors you know can look at
may be much larger areas of the image
but the main intuition when you take
away from this is just finding simpler
things like edges and then building them
up composing them together to detect
more complex things like an iron there
was in the composing those together to
find even more complex things and this
type of simple to complex hierarchical
representation or compositional
representation applies in other types of
data than images and and face
recognition as well for example if
you're trying to build a speech
recognition system it's hard to do
visualise speech but if you input an
audio clip there may be the first level
of a neural network might learn to
detect you know low level audio waveform
features such as is this tone going up
is this going down is it a white noise
or sibilant sound lights right and what
is the pitch but it can select to type
low level waveform features like that
and then by composing low level
waveforms maybe of learn to detect basic
units of sound so in linguistics they
called phonemes but for example in the
word cat the cup is a phoneme that up is
a phoneme the term is another phoneme
but learns to find maybe the basic units
of sound and then composing that
together maybe you learn to recognize
words in the audio and then maybe
compose those together in order to
recognize entire you know phrases or
sentences so deep neural network with
multiple hidden layers might be able to
have the earlier layers learn these
lower levels simpler features and then
have the later deeper layers then put
together the simpler things is detected
in order to detect more complex things
like recognize specific words or even
phrases or sentences that you
serving in order to carry-out speech
recognition and what we see is that
whereas the earlier layers are computing
what seems like relatively simple
functions of the input such as we're at
the edges by the time you get deep in
the network you can actually do you know
surprisingly complex things such as
detect faces or detect words or phrases
or sentences some people like to make an
analogy between deep neural networks and
the human brain where we believe on
neuroscientists believe that the human
brain also starts off detecting simple
things like edges in what your eyes see
and then builds those up to detect more
complex things like the faces that you
see I think analogies between deep
learning and the human brain are
sometimes a little bit dangerous but you
know there is a lot of truth to this
being how we think the human brain works
and that the human brain probably
detects simple things like edges first
and then puts them together to form more
and more complex objects and so that has
served as a loose form of inspiration
for some deep learning as well we'll say
a bit more about the human brain or
about the biological brain in a later
video this week the other piece of
intuition about why deep networks seems
to work well is the following so this
result comes from circuit theory which
pertains to thinking about what types of
functions you can compute with different
hand gates and or gates and not gates
bassy logic gates so informally their
functions in computer were viral ative
Li small but deep neural network and by
small I mean the number of hidden units
is relatively small but that if you try
to compute the same function with a
shallow network so if you aren't allowed
enough hidden layers then you might
require exponentially more hidden units
to compute so let me just give you one
example and illustrate this a bit
informally but let's say you're trying
to compute the exclusive-or or the
parity of all your input features you
can't compute X 1 X 4 X 2 X 4 X 3 X or
up to UM it
and if you have n or NX features so if
you build an X or tree like this right
so first compute the XOR of X 1 the next
two then take X 3 and X 4 and compute
their XOR and technically if you're just
using and or not gate you might need a
couple layers to compute the XOR
function rather than just one layer but
with a relatively small circuit you can
compute the XOR right and so on and then
you can you know build really an X or
tree like so until eventually you have a
circuit here that outputs you know the
all let's call this Y that outputs y hat
equals y the exclusive or the parity of
all of these input bits so the compute
the XOR the depth of the network will be
on the order of log n right when this
type of XOR tree so the number of nodes
and the number of circuit circuit
components or the number of gates in
this network is not that large you don't
need that many gates in order to compute
the exclusive-or but now if you're not
allowed to use a new network with
multiple hidden layers with in this case
order log and hidden layers if you're
forced to compute this function with
just one hidden layer right so you have
all these things going into you know
sort of hidden units and then these
things then outputs Y then in order to
compute the parity of X to compute this
XOR function this hidden layer will need
to be exponentially large because
essentially you need to exhaustively
enumerate all 2 to the N possible
configurations so on the order of 2 to
the N possible configurations of the
input bits that result in the exclusive
or being either
zero so you end up needing a hidden
layer that is exponentially large in the
number of bits I think technically you
could do this we have 2 to the N minus 1
hidden units right but that's the order
2 to the N is gonna be exponentially
large in the number of bits so hope this
gives a sense that there are
mathematical functions that are much
easier to compute with deep networks
than with shallow networks I have to
admit I personally found the result from
circuit theory less useful for gaining
intuitions but this is one of the
results that people often cite when just
when explaining the value of having very
deep representations now in addition to
these reasons for preferring deep neural
networks to be perfectly honest I think
the other reason the term term deep
learning has taken off
it's just branding right these things
used to be called neural networks above
all of hidden layers but the phrase deep
learning you know it's just a great
brand it just is so deep right so I
think that once that term called on that
really neuro networks rebranded or new
networks with many hidden layers
rebranded helped to capture the popular
imagination as well but regardless of
the PR branding deep networks do work
well sometimes people go overboard and
insist on using tons of hidden layers
but when I'm starting on a new problem I
often really start out with even
logistic regression and try something
with one or two hidden layers and use
that as a hyper parameter you said as a
parameter or hyper parameter that you
tune in order to try to find the right
therefore your neural network but over
the last several years there has been a
trend toward people finding that for
some applications very very deep neural
networks you know maybe many dozens of
layers sometimes can sometimes be the
best model for a problem so that's it
for the intuitions for why deep learning
seems to work well let's now take a look
at the mechanics of how to implement not
just for propagation but also back
propagation